- I could never have done what
you did, in order to get to--
- I love competition.
- See, yeah, me too.
But I just think--
- Even with yourself,
competing with yourself.
- Yeah, but I just think
it takes a certain level
of courage and confidence
to be able to go on a show
and break through that way.
I mean, I'm not being modest or anything.
I could never have done that.
I know what I'm capable of.
- Which is hysterical though
because your voice is like
what people are looking for.
- I wouldn't have done it.
I wouldn't have,
it takes I think a
certain amount of courage
to put yourself out there
and be judged in amongst
other people, right?
And be critiqued on a
show, on a world stage.
I don't know if anyone
realizes how hard that is,
to actually put yourself out there
and people tell you how good
you were or how bad you were,
and you having to take it
on a show like you did.
I wouldn't have had
the courage to do that.
And so I have so much admiration.
- Well, thank you.
- I think it was--
- But what was it like?
- Really good bootcamp though
because it was really hard.
And it was more hard not for
me but to watch other people.
I'm always that person,
like it's hard for me
to watch other people
go through something.
And like other artists
were not handling it well,
like what people would say online.
And it was the first time
the show was on or whatever,
so that was harder,
watching people break their spirit a bit.
I think, and that sucks,
but I will say it was a great
bootcamp because after that,
I felt like, I mean,
this industry is hard.
You say you couldn't handle it,
but you did because this
industry is not easy.
Even if you're selling 8 million
albums or doing whatever,
there's always people just
trying to knock you down
or say something just super (beep),
I can't say that on TV.
- But you went from nothing
to all of a sudden being exposed.
- But that's the trick though,
I think that is the key.
When you have no home,
my place had burned down,
I was living in my car for a bit,
like I had nothing.
I had nothing.
And I think when you have nothing,
you have nothing to lose
so you just show up and you
go, sure, you can laugh,
but if I'm getting paid,
I'm laughing all the way to the bank, so.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)